NEW FAVORITE PHRASE.
ROGER, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> GREAT TO BE HERE TUCKER.
MANY THANKS.
>> Tucker: MEANWHILE, THE HITS
KEEP COMING FOR LISA BLOOM.
A REPORT SAYS, THE LIBERAL
SUPER PAC AMERICAN BRIDGE FOR
SOME REASON.
LISA BLOOM $200,000 TO DO
SOLICIT SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
WE HAVE SOMEWHAT OF AN EXPERT ON
ETHICS WHO JOINS US TONIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ARE A
PROFESSIONAL ETHICIST OR NOT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ARE
REPRESENTING THE BAR
ASSOCIATION.
UP DIRT ON A POLITICAL
NOT SURE WHICH LISA BLOOM AND
HER MOTHER BELONG TO.
BUT THERE ARE DIFFERENT
INCENTIVES AT WORK HERE.
CLIENT MORE THAN ANY OTHER, AND
WHEN YOU HAVE A SET OF THESE TWO
ARE ENGAGED IN WHERE THEY HAVE
BEEN FISHING, ESSENTIALLY, FOR
STOOGES THAT THEY CAN PUT UP AS
STOOGES THAT THEY CAN PUT UP ASU
STOOGES THAT THEY CAN PUT UP ASP
STOOGES THAT THEY CAN PUT UP AST
STOOGES THAT THEY CAN PUT UP ASO
DAMAGE THE PRESIDENT SO THEY CAN
SET THEIR PRESS CONFERENCES, AS
THEY'VE BEEN DOING FOR MOST OF
THEIR LIVES, THEN I THINK THERE
>> Tucker: IT BOTHERS ME, IF
SHE WERE A POLITICAL CONSULTANT
OR A CONVENTIONAL SLIP-ANTI-FALL
CONSULTANT, YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
AGAINST DARKNESS, BUT SHE IS
TOTALLY CYNICAL TRANSACTIONAL
SLEAZY LAWYER.
>> YOU MENTIONED A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO, TUCKER, SHE WAS
HELPFUL.
I HAVE DONE THIS MYSELF.
TO HAVE A LAWYER WHO IS NOT ON
YOUR SIDE IDEOLOGICALLY AND
ACTUALLY IT JUST LOOKS AT THE
CASE FROM THE POINT OF THE LAW.
IT'S SOMETIMES ACTUALLY HELPFUL.
AS MIGHT BE HELPFUL TO HAVE A
FEMINIST LAWYER ACTUALLY
REPRESENTING A SCUMMY SLEAZE
BAG WHO ASSAULTS WOMEN.
WHAT MADE IT SLEAZY IS THAT SHE
HE WAS MAKING A TELEVISION
PRODUCTION OF HER BOOK.
THAT IS SLEAZY.
ON BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THEIR CLIENTS, AND IF YOU LOOK
AT LISA BLOOM AND HER MOTHER,
FOR EXAMPLE, ONE OF THE REASONS
THEY ARE RAISING MONEY, ONE OF
PAYS FOR THE INTERVIEW, THE
LAWYER GETS A THIRD OF THE FEE
AN AGENT, AND IT MAY WELL NOT BE
IN THE CLIENT'S INTEREST,
PARTICULARLY IF YOU ARE JUST
SOME ORDINARY WOMAN WHO HAPPENS
TO HAVE BEEN SIX SEXUALLY
TO BE GOING ON TELEVISION,
BECOMING A FAMOUS PERSON WHEN,
LIVING WITH THE CONSEQUENCES OF
HAVING BECOME A BRIEFLY FAMOUS
PERSON BUT STILL WITH NO MONEY
OR CELEBRITY OR ENDURING THING
TO SHOW FOR IT.
THAT IS NOT IN THE CLIENT'S
INTEREST.
>> Tucker: JUST A PARASITE
THAT I DON'T HAVE TO TAKE ANY
MORE MORAL LECTURES FROM LISA
BLOOM?
>> OH, NO.
ABSOLUTELY.
SAYING THAT SHE WANTS MONEY TO
HELP TAKE DOWN THE PRESIDENT.
YOU ARE NOT GIVING TO A PAC,
YOU'RE NOT GIVING TO A CAUSE,
OBJECTIVES.
AS YOU SAID, THE PARTICULAR
WOMEN IN THIS ISSUE, IN THIS
CASE, ARE ESSENTIALLY JUST
BACK OF THE DRESS AND MAKES THEM
SAY WHAT THEY SAY.
AS YOU SAID A COUPLE OF MINUTES
AGO.
AS LONG AS I CAN REMEMBER, I
HAVE SWITCHED ON THE TV, AND
HAPPENED, AND YOU NEVER HEAR
FROM THE WOMAN AGAIN, AND LISA